let's go next to um
there's just so many people that are
wanting to get on let's go to avi from
california avi you're on the air
uh hey david um so after the
trial derrick shelvin after he was found
guilty i hopped on a right-wing
telegram and it was a lot of people were
getting pissed off
i thought it was a guilty verdict yeah
and it wasn't just a cousin it's like
thousands of people
so what would be the best approach to
try to explain
to me these people like in real life
about why
he was found guilty see the thing that's
tough about this
is any time you're not
you know part of the try i mean some
people watched all of it okay
but very often people just react and say
it was the wrong result because it's not
the result that i wanted because of what
it means
politically or culturally rather than
this was an adjudication by the jurors
in the room of the facts in the case
and applying those facts to what the law
is
there have been lots of trials where the
verdicts have been things
i didn't want but you have to respect
the verdict because you're not
one of the jurors in this case i believe
that the verdict
does actually do something in terms of
hopefully signaling to police that that
there will be accountability
um so i don't you know to me it's less
about
convincing anyone that the verdict was
right or wrong
but more about the fact that if this is
the way we adjudicate these things
then it was fairly decided by a jury and
we have no choice but to stand by that i
i'm i'm not that
keen on arguing about the merits of the
case
um and a lot of my commentary in the
aftermath looking at right wing
media going completely bonkers is that
they sort of seem to be abandoning their
own principles about how we decide guilt
or innocence
because in this case they wanted not
guilty whereas it's like
it do do you respect that this is the
system we have or don't you
yeah it seems like they want criminal
justice for them but not for everyone
else
it's like with many of these things it's
like with medical issues
it's like with uh debt and deficit it's
they
they claim that they have certain values
but then as soon as those values
and infrastructure lead to an outcome
they don't want they throw away the fact
that they claim to re respect the system
we have it's pathetic
is it a signed question that's awesome
sure yeah
um what are your thoughts on modern
monetary theory oh i have i have uh
close to 10 clips about it uh i i've
done a bunch of interviews with some of
the top mmt people i mean generally
speaking my view is
a dollar of debt is not created equal
and what matters is what are we deficit
spending
in order to fund is it economically
stimulative or
isn't it and that's the way we should be
thinking about the national debt
all right thank you all right avi from
california
great to hear from you let's go next to
hayley from georgia haley you are on the
air
hey david this is the first time i've
called in great uh welcome
hi so my question um kind of starts off
with you know i'm from georgia i live in
augusta it's
the second most populous city in georgia
and we um are kind of split by two
different counties one very blue one
very red
um we worked extremely hard to remove
corrupt officials in the 2020
election um based on the majority vote
of our entire state
like electing senators and electing joe
biden sure and still it was extremely
close
um we almost didn't give our electoral
votes to biden
we almost didn't elect were not known
but district by district
there are many republicans that are
running unopposed in the general
assembly
and it's impossible to change our state
laws and our congressional
representation
um i've known a lot of our our
population is
tired um from all this uh all these
elections
um what more do you think that we can do
in 2022 to ensure that we don't lose
warnock
and also to change our state
representation
well the it's very important for people
to understand
that politics is much more than just
getting involved in presidential
or senate or even u.s congressional
seats and as you point out
a lot of what is being done when you
look at education
when you look at abortion when you look
at broadband i mean like all of these
issues
are hugely determined by the state
legislatures and state senates and so
i think what what we have to do is
constantly remind people
that particularly in places like georgia
with unopposed republicans
they have to start being opposed you
have to start mounting campaigns from
the left
and there's no shortage of opportunities
to get involved
it's really i think it's just really a
reminder haley a lot of people just
think about they vote for senate they
vote for president
and then that's basically it and you
have to start earlier
and you have to start building
candidates that can actually challenge
some of these
republicans now some of them may just
win because a lot of the way that the
the
state is sliced up um is good for
republicans
and so we have to we have to understand
that that we're up against that as well
but if they're unopposed then you don't
even have a shot right
i know it's so unfortunate yeah
thank you for answering my question i
just wanted to get that out there to
everybody too
yes and get involved in state senate
state legislature like haley is saying
yes all right haley thank you
yellow okay haley's gone thank you very
much haley
very important and that applies to just
about every state i would say every
state really